we are very excited because we've got a
very special edition Talk of the table
today we're joined by Drew Barrymore
host of The Drew Barrymore show you know
that energy news
co-host that's Ross Matthews like our
talk of the table in Jews news Drew and
Ross talk about their favorite stories
of the day it's one of my favorite
segments of the show so we're joining
forces to bring you some of the stories
that we are all talking about this
morning and Drew you're in Pole Position
pole position I love that you looked at
the graphics and went Graphics I do they
matter yeah I always notice them and I'm
gonna get off today all right finding
love can be tough in any town or city
but where you live might play a bigger
role than you think my talk at the table
is a new study from wallet Hub on the
best and worst cities in America to be
single the study ranked more than 180
cities on factors like the percentage of
population that is single the average
price for a two-person meal and the
number of attractions and at the bottom
of the list are Fort Smith Arkansas
Hialeah Florida Brownsville Texas and
Glendale California I want to go to the
best cities and we don't I don't want to
go there
you might need a warning on some of the
worst apparently Warwick Rhode Island
the study found that the top five best
cities for dating are Portland Oregon uh
San Francisco Denver Madison Wisconsin
and at number one Seattle
if you're wondering about New York City
it was ranked number 151 out of 182 Gale
that might explain a few things to us
yes yes what a lot of concrete hearts in
the concrete
that I really like to pick a city that
has things that you're interested if
you're a hiker and you like nature like
go to that City if you're a city person
move to that City so that was a good tip
I'm sorry but are there any cities that
it's great to be single in no I don't
think so because you love love I love
love can't help it me too sorry not
about Seattle though that's right
all right I talk at the table is a story
about how it's never too late in life to
reinvent yourself meet Van Gogh a
homeless senior dog who like his famous
namesake only has one ear and his
shelter says he was rescued from a dog
fighting ring they say he's very
friendly and always happy but no one
wanted to adopt him so they had to get
creative that you got to Market these
dogs and they had Van Gogh start
painting look at that they put some
Globs of paint on canvas and covered it
in plastic wrap and then coated that
with peanut butter and Van Gogh went
wild and while he was snacking in the
peanut butter he was actually painting
his own version of Starry Night and the
shelter held an online auction for Van
Gogh's painting and they sold out look
at it the dog dig that with the peanut
butter and best of all Van Gogh was
adopted on the last day of the auction
this is so special happy ending I work
with the Palm Springs Animal Shelter I
live in Palm Springs when I'm not here
with Drew in New York and there are so
many dogs out there who need homes and a
great way to get creative and make a
story I mean again go is my hero I'm so
glad that you explained that there was
plastic because I thought they're
letting the dog eat the paint I was
confused yeah so I'm glad you explained
that Ross that's a good one I thought
the same thing yeah like I talk to the
table of somebody that we all know
around here msnbc's Stephanie rule
welcome to Stephanie I know love her
Beyond calling out the thief this is so
good who stole some packages outside her
home here in New York security cameras
show the person opening the gate look at
this guy walking toward the door you can
see the holiday Grinch lean in I'm sorry
we blur it out his face because if go
online you can see his face somebody
knows this guy somebody knows him please
turn him in go on Stephanie's Twitter
pick up the boxes before leaving
packages in tow so Stephanie wasn't at
home she wasn't at home obviously she's
not going to let it slide without a
little retaliation so she tweeted this
this is my favorite part to whomever
stole the packages in front of my my
door I hope you have good use for my
daughter's Christmas show costume it's
too late to get another and she will be
absolutely heartbroken and if you get
really sweaty in the sports clothes that
you stole that's not sweat it's kids
tears wow and I think it's the time of
year where people are going on people's
property taking stuff there's a lot I'm
so glad Stephanie that you called it out
and that we put it up and please go to
her her Twitter so you can see who this
is because I think somebody helps her
get her costume yeah no that's what I
was thinking I was hoping another parent
might be got two yes maybe someone can
sew we've got wardrobe departments
exactly let's get Project Runway on the
phone yeah exactly the world all right
so my talk on the table which I teased
earlier in the show is about my year-end
Spotify list yes artists genres and
songs I listen to the most now a lot of
people are thinking you're a
40-something dad you probably listen to
country music I'm not really interested
in your list okay and you would be right
based on the genre top five genres we
have that chart it says country is
number one contemporary country is off
is also there number four so you're
bored but to my surprise despite this
genre list so it might give you a
certain idea about me here are my top
five songs what do you got here they
were very cool you're sharing they were
very cool Tony okay nothing but Harry
Styles and not only oh my God not only
are those my top five songs but Spotify
informs me that I am in the top one
percent of Harry Styles listeners
worldwide so proud of you Dale and I
went to Harry Styles concert together
approve of this list because that album
is so good and the concert was like
transformative it really was it was more
than a concert look at Tony Drew in the
kitchen
and Tony you did a profile on him years
ago before he really blew up before he
blew up we got a lot of time with him
he's a lovely man uh and he's a hell of
an artist oh for sure and human Sunshine
yeah of course Nate you are my favorite
story uh-huh I have a good story for you
so we like to do stories about Florida
men because we have one here at the
table but my chocolate table is a
lawsuit over how long it takes to make a
certain mac and cheese a woman in
Florida that's why I would have proposed
five million dollar class action suit
against Kraft Heinz the maker of a
Velveeta cheese and shells shells and
cheese that is she accuses the company
of false advertising and fraud so here's
the thing on the label the box says
Ready in three and a half minutes but
the lawsuit claims that's not true at
all the 15 pages 15 page document points
out that you have to remove the lid in
the cheese sauce pouch add the water to
the cup stir then microwave for three
and a half minutes and you're still not
done you still have to add the contents
of the cheese sauce pouch the woman
claims she was duped yeah and all of
this takes much longer than proposed CNN
reports that Kraft Heinz caused the
lawsuit frivolous
sit down and take several seats
you look on the box it's ridiculous and
it's supposed to be three and a half
minutes and you're a parent and you got
kids they're hungry that's right or you
gotta be somewhere it's ridiculous I
mean by the way I just learned something
I didn't know craft owned uh well
doesn't that make sense Velveeta our
Heinz well craft and Hines that's a
monopoly and um I just love craft
macaroni and cheese I do love a Velveeta
Shells and cheese though if I'm gonna
you're human yeah but I didn't know it
was all in the same family no but I like
how she takes it seriously it's like if
my pizza's not here in 30 minutes or
less I'm seeing you in court all right
we'll see you again you're the master of
the microwave come on
I hope that the lawyer that wrote that
uh 15-page complaint is giving a little
talk at a law school that'd be packed
packed auditory well we're talking about
it I know you know maybe she's got a
point what you're working on lately
that's a big case good to have you guys
I love you guys
Ross Matthews lovely to have you here
appreciate it guys all right the Drew
Barrymore show airs weekdays on stations
all around the country check your local
listings you guys laughing at me we're
so excited we are here with you